[Music]
Hello friends welcome to your program
3abn today Bible Q&A my name is idalia
deny and it's a privilege and a pleasure
for me to uh greet you during this hour
and share this hour with you um we have
the panelists this hour who have been
receiving the comments and questions uh
from you all our family thank you that
we receive your comments and questions
from around the world and praise God for
technology because it is said and the
Bible says that this Gospel of the
Kingdom shall be preached to all the
world right Nation Kindred tongues and
people and you are participating from
abroad and we thank you well the
panelist during this hour it consists of
Pastor John loming welcome pastor always
good to be here and I know it's going to
be a good program and uh today we have a
little different setup so I'm looking
forward to it yes it is but same word
though same word same word that's right
and we have my very own John deny
welcome thank you it's a privilege to be
here and it's a blessing and we want to
thank everyone for sending their
questions it helps us to dig deeper into
some areas that maybe we wouldn't look
into because we have people with
different mindsets they looking at
different things so it's a blessing that
is correct and no question or comment is
too simple and no question or comment is
too hard because uh as I witness at home
fascinating John Deni will come to me
honey look at this isn't this marvelous
it says this and that as he studies for
answering in these um programs so praise
the Lord that you all spend that quality
time in studying deeply well guys uh we
received comments from different parts
of the world but before we get into the
questions um I'd like to do two things
I'd like to pray and also share the
contact information because as soon as
the turns on I'm sure it has happened to
me I'm like oh I had a question to send
in and I forgot to send it in so we'd
like to uh of course ask the Lord to be
with us and to be with you and for him
to anoint our ears and our hearts so we
can hear his word as we study so I'm
going to ask um John deny would you
please pray sure let's go to the Lord in
prayer Our loving Heavenly Father we
want to thank you thank you Lord for the
holy scriptures yes they are a light to
our path and there is a treasure of
wisdom amen and there is so much to
learn that we know you want to teach us
Lord and we are barely just looking at
the surface because we are going to
continue studying these things we ask
Lord that you will bless us during this
program bless us with the Holy Spirit
Lord we we do not want to speak our
words we pray that you will speak
through us and we pray that you will
give your children understanding of the
things you want to share and we ask you
for these things in the holy and blessed
name of Jesus Amen am amen amen all
right thank you so much and now uh as
far as sending your text in with your
comments or questions I'd like to share
that number now and you can send a text
to 618 228 3975 it's on the screen 618
228 3975 greeting our radio listeners
too of course and you can send your
email to Bible QA 3abn TV Bible
QA
3abn.org
ABN official right now we're going to
address the first question that came
from lenx can Canada and he send it from
via a text can you please explain what
is meant by offering up spiritual
sacrifices as mentioned in 1 Peter 2:5
John Den thank you so much uh there in 1
Peter 2:5 we have those wonderful words
about offering spiritual sacrifices let
me go ahead and look that up over here
in the Bible so that we can read it
together and that is a very good
question you know most people don't
think about that aspect of ministry and
that is offering up spiritual sacrifices
1 Peter chapter 2 and verse 5 these are
the words we find there you also as
living stones are being built up a
spiritual house a holy priesthood to
offer the spiritual sacrifices
acceptable to God through Jesus Christ
and so that is a good question what are
those spiritual sacrif Rices now we go
to Hebrews chap 13: 15 and 16 notice
what it says here by him therefore let
us offer the sacrifice of praise to God
continually so the sacrifice of praise
is one of those spiritual sacrifices
that we are to offer well praising God
and yes you can praise God by where you
are by yourself alone but also people
need to see those sacrifices of Praise
people need to uh see and hear that you
are praising God for the wonderful
things that he does notice he says that
is the fruit of our lips giving thanks
to his name so when in front of people
that do not know the Lord you're
offering the sacrifice of praise
praising God oh praise the Lord I feel
good today praise the Lord he has uh
blessed us with what we need in our home
oh he blessed us with a a vehicle he
blessed us with a job so these are
sacrifices of praise
that you offer to the Lord continuing in
Hebrews 13:16 but to do good and to
communicate forget not for with such
sacrifices God is well pleased so to do
good to others that even you give of the
things that God has given to you you are
offering a sacrifice of a spiritual
sacrifice to the Lord now I want to
point this out because in Matthew
chapter 27 verse 50 and 51 helps us to
understand that we are not to offer
animal sacrifices anymore no more Lambs
no more Goats No More Rams let's go to
Matthew 27: 5051 and Jesus cried out
again with a loud voice and yielded up
his Spirit then behold the veil of the
temple was torn into from top to bottom
and the earthquake and the Rocks were
split this is a very interesting passage
of scripture because the Bible is
telling us the story of Jesus dying on
the cross for us and suddenly it changes
the scene completely from Calvary from
the cross Jesus dying to the temple a
different scene and there it says that
the veil of the temple which was very
high and very thick very thick I put my
hands this way so you can see very thick
was torn into from the top to the bottom
putting an end to the sacrifices as was
prophesied in Daniel chapter 9 so Jesus
the sacrifice of Jesus ends all animal
sacrifices so now we are to offer the
sacrifices spiritual sacrifices
sacrifice to praise the fruit of our
lives and giving thanks to the Lord and
to do good things these are the
spiritual sacrifices that we are to
offer to the Lord amen amen thank you
very much for explaining that now Pastor
loang on a previous program you talked
about wearing jewelry saying it was part
of how the Egyptians used it to guide
their soul from being taken by an evil
spirit what does it mean for this
generation please help me understand
thanks I'm a bimbola from United Kingdom
sent that Emil okay wow that's a
pronounced that name pretty good that
was a tough one but now the Egyptians
use it to guard their souls I think you
use the phrase guide here but to guard
their souls and this is a pagan practice
that still prevalent today in many
cultures where the worship of the true
God is Not uh partaken of but now you
ask the question what does this mean for
us in this generation of Seventh Day
Adventist now first first thing we have
to point out is Generations don't change
God's word the word of God is not a book
that changes with generations and the
reason is Malachi 3:6 I am the Lord I do
not change in Hebrews 13:8 Jesus Christ
is the same yesterday today and forever
so the word does not change it endures
forever what changes our cultures and
generations prime example even still
today in the Middle East people dress
differently than we do here in America
we in Dubai and different parts of the
Middle East and India and other
countries and we see wow well when the
person says a woman should not wear a
man's garment well women don't dress how
women dress in America and men don't
dress how men dress in America you go to
Saudi Arabia you don't see men with
suits very rare but they have on a
different type of garment altogether but
when it came to the uh article of
jewelry and we go back to the Egyptians
because when the Lord led the Egyptians
when the Lord led the Israelites out of
Egypt there was a consistency that you
find not just introduced in the book of
Exodus but also introduced in Genesis
and one of the things that we I want to
put this in the context the wearing of
jewelry fits into the same Principle as
unclean and clean Meats now many people
say well I'm not going to eat that I'm
not going to smoke that I'm not going to
drink that and I'll say why they said
because my body is the Temple of the
lord well let me ask a very important
question if you are approaching any
Great temple in America wherever it's
built however wonderful it looks what do
you see first you don't see the inside
first you see the outside and so we have
to keep this in mind it's not just the
inside of our bodies that belong to the
Lord It's the outside so look at the
injunctions that the Lord gives let's
start with Genesis 35: 1-4 because God
is calling Jacob to sanctify and bless
his family prepare them for the work
ahead of them and notice what Jacob says
Genesis 35:1 and God said to Jacob arise
go up to bethl and dwell there and make
an altar there to God who appeared to
you when you fled from the face of Esau
your brother notice what Jacob told his
family to do in verse two and Jacob said
to his household and to all who were
with him put away the foreign Gods
another translation says the strange
gods that are among you purify El and
change your garments and notice how they
responded with that uh uh uh commission
from Jacob verse 4 of Genesis 35 so they
gave Jacob all the foreign Gods which
were in their hands because Layman laan
Jacob's wife's father sold foreign gods
and all the earrings which were in their
ears and Jacob hid them under the terbin
tree which was by sheum or he buried
them under the oak tree which was by
sheum notice he didn't just take them
off and leave them home he buried them
saying we cannot sanctify ourselves to
the Lord and partake in idols and
jewelry that's the first injunction then
you go to the children of Israel coming
out of the the children of Israel coming
out of the land of Egypt and you find
this the lord gave the children of
Israel all the jewels of the Egyptians
to build the Tabernacle everything
needed some kind of emerald some kind of
Jewel to build the Tabernacle but
instead they started wearing it like the
Egyptians wore it and in the Egyptian
culture they wore it for the purpose of
protecting themselves from Spirits
coming in but notice this very quickly
Exodus
33:5 the Lord said to Moses say to the
children of Israel you are a stiff neck
people I can come in your midst in a
moment and consume you now therefore
take off your ornaments that I may know
what to do with you so the children of
Israel stripped themselves of their
ornaments by Mount by Mount horb and
then what else what do they do as a
result I'm giving you the short version
Exodus 35: 22 what did they strip
themselves of and what did that entail
and they came both men and women and as
many as had a willing heart and look at
the Articles they brought earrings and
nose rings rings and necklaces all
jewelry of gold that is every man who
made an offering of gold to the Lord and
others went wood and stone whatever the
offering was they brought it and gave it
to the Lord but here's the key now Paul
in the New Testament summarizing is that
this way recognizing the body to belong
to God 2 Corinthians 6:16 what agreement
has the temple of God with Idols for you
are the Temple of the Living God as God
had said I will dwell in them and walk
among them I will be their God and they
shall be my people and finally
Revelation 17:4 shows a picture of a
woman in apostasy and what is she
described as wearing precious stones and
pearls and gold and having a cup of
Abominations so the question is if you
want to represent the Lord allow the
Beauty the natural beauty as Peter says
which is an ornament of a Meek and quiet
Spirit which in the sight of God is of
great price that's how the people of God
should represent him not with the
ornamentation of the world not which
that not with that which represents
other
gods amen thank you so much for all the
biblical uh teaching what we are moving
on to U Ben's questions he is from
maritus and he sent an email okay then
see get ready it says when Jesus spoke
about Sin for example adultery he
mentioned that even thinking about about
adultery is sin is he implying that it
is impossible for us humans to not sin
if so why did he tell the woman who was
to be stoned you are forgiven go forth
and sin no more is he implying that the
woman is dead H thank you very much Ben
for that question very very interesting
the way you put these verses together
because on the one hand uh you're
showing that Jesus said uh that a man
that looks at a woman and lusts after
her it's not a sin to look at a woman a
man what you can look at things but
lusting becomes the problem let's go
ahead and read Matthew
25: 27 and 28 you have heard that it was
said to those of old you shall not
commit adulter
but I say to you that whoever looks at a
woman to Lust For Her has already
committed adultery with her in his heart
so we have here Jesus going helping
people to understand more about God's
law about do not commit adultery it's
not just the physical act that becomes a
sin but also the lusting the working out
of that lust or that idea of adultery in
the mind because uh there was a point in
time that Jesus said to them these
people honor me with their lips but
their heart is far from me imagine
somebody is sitting in a church and
they're praising and singing songs but
they're looking at the women and lusting
after them they're singing praises to
God but they're lusting after the women
then you are not you are not praising
God with your whole heart you're you
have a divided heart and you are
committing adultery in your heart so
this is a sin no Jesus is not implying
that it is
impossible to uh not sin because you
choose to sin we choose to think about
things and so in Isaiah 42:21 it says
the Lord is well pleased for his
righteousness sake he will magnify the
law and make it honorable Jesus here is
magnifying the law he's helping us to
understand more the law about do not
commit adultery so this includes the
idea of thinking now you say in your
question is he implying that it is
impossible for us humans to not sin no
because look at John
chapter uh 8 which you quoted I'm going
to read it really quick it says when
Jesus had raised himself up and saw no
one but the woman he said to to her
woman there where are those accusers of
your own of yours has no one condemned
you she said no one Lord and Jesus said
to hurt neither do I condemn you go and
sin no more there is no indication here
that the woman is dead the Jesus
delivered her from being killed she
continued to live after this experience
so what Jesus said to her go and sin no
more is he saying to her an
impossibility no Jesus is saying you can
go and sin no more why because With God
all things are possible that's right
let's look ahead let's go to John 15:5
this is Jesus talking he says I am the
vine you are the branches he who abides
in me and I in him Bears much fruit for
without me you can do nothing that's
right so without Jesus we can do nothing
we're going to continue sinning we're
just going to do whatever we please and
dishonor God hurt ourselves and hurt
others M Philippians 4: 13 uh tells us
this is Paul speaking he says I can do
all things through Christ who
strengthens me Jesus came to show us
that with him all things are possible
that it is possible to live a life
dedicated to God and not to sin and
that's why Jesus says without me you can
do nothing so we need to unite ourselves
with Jesus we need to abide in Jesus
connect ourselves to him who is the
branch I mean the the Divine and we are
the branch connect ourselves to him so
that we can have Victory through him
amen amen and praise the Lord that he is
readily available well folks I would
like to once again share the contact
information so that you too can share
your questions and comments so we invite
you to send your texts to 618 22839
975 that is 618 228
3975 the email is Bible QA
3abn.org
you can find us at 3abn uncore official
3abn uncore official well we move on to
the next question and Pastor loang is
ready to respond to Jillian from Florida
who sent in the text in the great
controversy I know that Satan took
onethird of the angels with him when he
was cast out of Heaven the angels that
were cast out with him were deceived by
him is it possible they can repent and
have acceptance back into heaven in the
end times Asom gang wow this could be a
really quick answer no and let me but
let me give you the scriptural evidence
for that we don't know the Bible doesn't
tell us how long this process of
deception took place but Ezekiel gives
us an example it says by the multitude
of your trading and what did what did
Lucifer do in the courts of Heaven he
was trading light for Darkness Truth for
deception and I didn't just say error
because error did not exist in heaven he
Trad Truth for deception he he went
around campaigning from one Angel to the
other until he su successfully in the
final Rebellion caused one3 to be cast
out with him Revelation 12: 7 and 8
makes it very very clear about this war
but verse 8 in Revelation 12 speaking
about the angels and it says
um but they did not prevailed speaking
of the dragon and his angels the dragon
representing Satan but notice the last
part of verse eight nor was a place
found for them in heaven any
longer you you're not coming back this
level of rebellion cannot be allowed to
continue here now just use it in basic
everyday situations okay you say a guy
um who's a head teller of the bank or
the bank manager he was found to
embezzle a million and a half dollars
over the course of a year and he says
you know I'm really sorry I'd like to be
the bank manager
again really not not in this Bank you
might go and sell some ices on the
corner of the bank but we're not going
to put that back in front of you ever
again right there's repentance then
there is replacement you find this
similarity with Judas he repented not
because he was sorry but because he got
caught and Judas at that point once the
Lord said whatever you must do do
quickly from that moment his fate was
sealed he went out and got caught he was
found in his sin and then he was so
upset he threw the uh the pieces of gold
silver back to the chief priest but they
said hey I we don't care about that
money we already use you for what we
want and he went out and was so angry he
hung himself well he was sorrowful but
that he got caught not that he repented
so there's no chance of the Angels going
back into heaven can you imagine if you
are an angel and you say hey I heard
that um uh the angel the angel Nicholas
is coming back are you kidding mean the
one that left with Lucifer he's coming
back you guys better watch him you
better keep your eyes on him that's
right because we went through a whole
lot trying to get him to change his mind
and he's back listen to what he says
because maybe he's here as a plant be
careful because these things are deep
the Lord knew exactly what he was doing
that's why second Peter and Jude 1 makes
these points very clear for if God
second Peter 2 verse4 for if God did not
Spar the Angels who sin but cast them
down to hell that's the only place the
word hell is to taros the spiritual
world where they are bound in
limitations Bound by spiritual chains
delivered them into chains of Darkness
to be reserved for judgment that's the
only thing they're looking forward to
and Jude 1:6 and the angels who did did
not keep their proper domain or former
Abode but left their own Abode he has
reserved in Everlasting chains under
Darkness for the Judgment of the great
day so they're looking forward to
judgment they know it's coming and the
evidence of that is in Revelation
12:2 Rejoice oh heavens and you who
dwell in them but woe to the inhabitants
of the earth and of the Sea Watch this
for the devil has come down to you
having great wrath because he knows he
has a short time he knows it amen his
angels know it so no they will not have
a chance of returning to Heaven their
days are limited and because why
Nehemiah 1:9 sin will not rise up
Affliction will not rise up a second
time amen amen thank you so much Pastor
we're looking to Heaven all right uh we
move along and we thank Ken from New
York who sent in this following question
John Dy will answer how do we know
stepen was stoned in 34
ad thank you Ken that's a good question
that's a good question uh it seems to me
that you are asking this question
because you have some understanding of
the prophecy in Daniel chapter 8 and
Daniel chapter n and we may be able to
talk about that in a moment so how do we
know that he was Stone in 34 ad we have
to look at Clues we have to look for
evidence or things that help us
understand the time frame so this is why
we go to a couple of scriptures one in 2
Corinthians and one in Galatians chapter
1 2 Corinthians 11:32 and 33 notice what
it says here in the Mascus the governor
under aritas the king kept the city of
damine with a Garrison desires to
apprehend me this is Paul talking and
through a window in a basket was I let
down by the wall and escaped his hand so
this particular scriptures help us to
understand a time frame because it
mentions uh the aritas and that they
were Desiring to apprehend him this
scripture I mean the uh the historical
information uh tells us that what
happened in second Corinthians 11:32 and
33 was about the middle of 37 ad because
of historical re record for in the year
37 ad orus took control of that City so
if this happened in 37 ad and Paul is
being persecuted he is a Christian so
Paul was instrumental in Stephen being
stoned he was there he was not a
Christian at that point so this 34 ad is
is uh before Paul becomes a Christian so
at 37 ad we have to go back and say okay
some somewhere in the past
he was not a Christian so Galatians
chapter 1 it says uh Paul talking uh
Galatians 1:17 18 neither went I up to
Jerusalem when he became a Christian to
them which were Apostles before me but I
went into Arabia so he spent some time
in Arabia and returned again into
Damascus then after three years I went
up to Jerusalem to see Peter and ab Bo
with him 15 days so there's this time
frame here that Paul was a Christian
spent 3 years and so we have to go back
before 37 ad so how do we know it is a
deduction based on evidence the on that
I mentioned in 2 Corinthians 11:32 and
33 but also because of the prophecy of
Daniel chapter uh 9 and in Daniel
chapter 9 we do not have time let me go
ahead and read as much as I can Daniel
chapter 9 verse 24- 27 the 70 weeks
notice say 70 weeks are determined for
your people and for your Holy City to
finish the transgression and to make an
end of sins to make reconciliation for
iniquity to bring in Everlasting
righteousness to seal up the vision and
prophecy and to anoint the most holy so
this is a prophecy and it says 70 weeks
are determined for your people that is
the people of Israel and so 70 weeks
from the starting point of 457 BC it's
490 years this is prophetic time one day
for a year this time frame beginning
with
457 uh BC ends in 34 ad so looking at
the clues we see uh you also need to
read all the way to verse 27 because let
me read verse 27 then he shall confirm a
covenant with many for one week that is
Jesus but in the middle of the week he
shall bring an end to sacrifice and
offering that is Jesus dying on the
cross that's 31 ad and um and that's so
the middle of the week 31 ad three more
three and a half years are left
so uh we go to to the time when Steven
is stoned the same type of scenario is
presented to us there notice uh there in
Acts chapter 6 in Acts chapter 6 uh
verse 8 it says and Steven full of faith
and power did great wonders and miracles
among the people they were not happy
about this so in verse 12 it says and
they stirred up the people and the
elders and the scribes and came upon him
and and caught him caught Steven and
brought him to the councel and set up
false Witnesses which said the man
ceaseth not to speak Blasphemous words
against this holy place and the law the
same type of scenario is with Jesus in
Matthew chapter 26 beginning in verse 57
and they had laid hold on Jesus led him
away to Caiaphas the high priest where
the scribes and the elders were
assembled in the council notice verse 59
now the chief priests and elders and all
the council same thing that happened
with that time of Steven sought false
Witnesses against Jesus to put him to
death but found none ye y though many
false Witnesses came yet found they none
and so same type of scenario so we have
these two events and that uh we come to
the conclusion that it happened in 34 ad
that's how we can find out this w wow
very interesting lot of historical
footprint that is very well presented
thank you Dy all right well we're going
to move on to we received a text and
this is quite a question here my family
member this is for pastor Lin by the way
my family member tells me and others
that we are going to hell if we don't go
to church on Saturday I read Colossians
2:16 I have been standing on that verse
is my family correct okay well let me
give you encouragement nobody could
assign us to hell that's a decision made
by Divinity mhm now second L we don't
even Teach as a church and we keep the
Sabbath that people that go to church on
Sunday are going to hell when a person
becomes aware of God's requirements and
then reject those that's a different
story when you know the Bible says to
him that knows to do good and do it not
to him it is sin and what is sin sin is
the transgression of the law Paul says I
would have not known sin except the law
had said in the law of God it says
remember the Sabbath to keep it holy if
you are a Christian and you are aware of
God's law and you are aware of that he
says to you remember the Sabbath to keep
it holy and your response is no I'm not
going to do that I want to do the day
that I prefer then you are accountable
to that and there is no other Journey or
destination other than being destroyed
in hell but this comes to accountability
not just an assignment because your
family is upset we can't assign anyone
to being destroyed but let me caution
you if you study God's word and you know
that the Lord is saying to you remember
the Sabbath to keep it holy broadly if
you love me keep my Commandments and you
say no Lord I do love you but I'm not
going to keep your Commandments you are
in danger you're putting your salvation
in danger so don't lean it on your
family and say because they said this is
the reason I'm not going to keep the
Sabbath don't put your family in the
equation do what God's word says don't
do it because they said it don't hold
your ground as you said I'm standing on
that verse stand on God's word that's
where the safety comes in secondly
Colossians 2:16 has nothing to do with
the Bible Sabbath of creation this is a
Sabbath that was connected Ed to the
ceremonies that's why Paul says let no
one judge you in food and drink and
regard of festivals of new moon or
sabbaths all five of those components
were components of the ceremonial system
and when the Lord as Pastor DJI just
explained the temple curtain was torn
from top to bottom bringing an end to
the sacrificial system all those
mattered no more because they all only
functioned to point to the work of
Christ Jesus the Water of Life the
drinks Jesus the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world 1 John 29 Behold
the Lamb of God all these were symbols
in the ceremonial service so when Jesus
came the light of the world the
candleabra the Water of Life the labor
the the showbread the bread of life all
these things pointed to Jesus when he
came the temple curtain and all of his
significance and all that Services came
to an end those are festivals so when
Paul says let no one judge you he's
saying to the colossian Christians who
were under the imposition of the Jews
saying you got to keep the feasts they
said no we do not have to keep the feast
first Corinthians 7:19 was also an issue
there and Paul says circumcision avails
nothing and uncircumcision avails
nothing but what matters is keeping the
Commandments of God so that's applying
to us today we don't have to keep Feast
that's what that's referring to and very
quickly the the examples of some of
these feasts there were approximately
about five or six feasts one and you can
go back to these I'll give you the
references the Feast of first fruits or
the wave sheef offerings that took place
the day after the Sabbath in Leviticus
23: 9-14 look it up then the Feast of
Weeks also known as Pentecost which were
50 days after the Sabbath in Leviticus
23:1 15- 21 that was a second ceremonial
Sabbath then the Feast of trumpets the
first day of the seventh month Leviticus
23: 23-2 and then the day of atonement
another Sabbath the Sabbath this was on
the the 10th day of the seventh month
but then this trumpets were blown for
nine days and then they were signaling
that the day of atonement was coming
Leviticus chap 23 vers 26-32 and then
the Feast of Tabernacles another Feast
this took place the first and eth day of
the seventh month and the the warning of
this or the coming of it was signal to
be the 15th day of the month you find
that Leviticus CH 23: 33 to 43 I hope
you caught those references but here's a
nutshell of it the Sabbath is an
obligation to all Christians Mark 2: 27-
28 the Sabbath was made for man and not
man for the Sabbath and Ezekiel 20:12
and2 the Sabbath is a sign between us
and God that we might know that he is
the Lord who sanctifies us if the Lord
says to keep the Sabbath holy remember
Exodus 20:10 the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord your God here's the
question who is your
god amen amen all right thank you very
much I think this topic could cover one
whole hour yes all right thank you for
the person that sent in that text we
don't have the name for that person
because they wanted to just send it
anonymously okay Erica we want to thank
you for your email so jeni how could the
devil enter the snake in the Garden of
Eden but the demons couldn't go into the
pigs without permission how did Satan
get permission to enter the
serpent very good question and I want to
thank you for sending it because uh very
interesting uh see you youve mentioned
something that is a a principle that the
Lord reveals to us in the scriptures
also uh helps us to understand that
There Are Rules of Engagement There Are
Rules of Engagement and this is why you
see what you mention about the pigs
asking for permission they know they
can't do whatever they want they have to
get permission let's go ahead and read
Matthew 8: 30-32 uh for for the benefit
of those that are not aware why you
mentioned this now uh Jesus comes to to
a place and um he uh delivers somebody
gives Liberty to someone that was
possessed by demons now it says in verse
30 now a good way off from them there
was a herd of many swine feeding so the
demons begged them saying if you cast us
out permit us to go away into the her of
swine wonderful scripture they cannot
even possess animals without permission
so they cannot possess animals without
permission they cannot Poss possess
people without permission Rules of
Engagement so in essence um God gives
permission for the Devils to enter into
animals if they ask for permission but
also people if they ask for permission
but if the person has opened doors to
the devil if you open doors to the devil
you are inviting the devil and so this
is uh uh we will have to spend more time
on that but Rules of Engagement and so
verse 32 and he said to them go so when
they had come out they went into the
herd of swine they had received
permission what happens what were the
results and suddenly the whole herd of
swine ran violently down the Steep Place
into the sea and perished in the water
it is dangerous to be possessed by
demons dangerous you see what kind of
things they do here so the question is
how did the devil get into the Garden of
Eden and um use the serpent so the
serpent was used as a
medium the devil spoke through the
serpent but because we have this
scripture that we just read about the
devil's asking for permission they must
have asked the devil must have asked
permission from God to be able to use
the serpent the devil cannot do whatever
he wants we see pictures of God holding
the Four Winds of strife through through
the Angels the four the Four Angels
holding the Winds of strife the devil
asked for permission this is the safe
conclusion we can come to notice 1
Corinthians 10:13 no temptation has
overtaken you except such as is common
to man but God is faithful who will not
allow you to be tempted beyond what you
are able but with the Temptation will
also make the way of Escape that you may
be able to Bear it God weighs every
Temptation God measures every Temptation
so that
only what God allows is allowed to come
to you if you are following the Lord if
you are being faithful to the Lord
notice here in Luke
22:31 again the devil asking for
permission and it says and the Lord said
Simon Simon behold Satan hath desired to
have you that he may sit you as sweet
the devil's asking for permission so in
the same way the devil ask permission to
use the serpent to tempt
Eve protection we have is evidenced in
the Bible in many ways uh we already
read one let's look at Psalms 34:7 the
angel of the Lord encamps all around
those who fear Him and delivers them God
has his Sentinels his angels guarding
the way Satan cannot do whatever he
wants he asked for permission to enter
into the garden and to use the serpent
that is the only safe conclusion we can
come
to wow yes I would love another program
just about this topic it's very good
it's amazing with all these questions it
could be a whole by itself right away I
was thinking about uh job you know that
he went to God and Pastor L was speaking
so fast trying to share as many
scriptures as he could in the space of
time he has more more stuff to share of
course well it's it's a blessing to dig
into the word and thank you for the
encouragement at home and thank you for
your text this text came from
Pennsylvania and it says Pastor l what
does A House Divided cannot stand mean
okay A house divided against itself
cannot stand I'll use a very loose
illustration if if Pastor deny and I are
on the same team and he's working
against me we're going to lose that's
right the simple point of the matter is
and this is all through the word of God
A house divided against itself you know
the Bible says a man's foes will be
those of his own household there a lot
of families who have divided homes the
parents want them to go to church they
want to go to the movies they want to go
to the clubs they want to go to party
they want to smoke marijuana they want
to drink that's a divided house and in
many cases a house that's divided cannot
stand it's weak in other words the
foundation is it may be on a Christian
Foundation but those who are in the
house are at odds with one another it
cannot stand that's why it's important
all sports teams they all wear the same
Jersey they all want to win they're all
on the same team the only irony of that
is in humanity we sometimes are on
opposite sides of the issue opposite
sides of the coin and that's pretty much
what Jesus meant but he now puts it in a
spiritual context look at Matthew
12:2 Jesus knowing their thought
thoughts said to them speaking to the
Pharisees every Kingdom divided against
itself divided against itself is brought
to Desolation and every city or house
divided against itself will not stand
you can't have people working for you
that are on the enemy of the side of the
enemy yes we call those plants who's
giving all the information those are
people on the inside and the principle
of Amos 3:3 can two walk together unless
they are agreed what's the answer no
matter of fact if you go card and I
talked to somebody recently that they
said well you know in my opinion I'm
right and in your opinion you're right I
said let's put that opinion thing aside
and allow the word of God to be our
guide because people like to use God's
word to support their opinions when
God's word what's the purpose of it for
for for uh for teaching for for prophecy
also for Repro for correction for
instruction in righteousness the word of
God is the book that's correcting us and
so when we are AR way nobody argues with
their GPS at least I don't know of that
anymore now in the first stages people
their GPS will lead him into a lake but
it's now refined so that people don't
say I've never been on this road before
my wife has said to me well just follow
it let's just see what else we learn so
wow I I never knew that way to back you
know the back way to uh to to Maran we
learned some unusual ways but sometimes
you make a turn and we say where are we
she said just turn your GPS on it always
guides us God's word guides us but if we
say no I don't believe that's the way I
do believe that's the way husbands and
wives always argue about directions and
the GPS always settle the arguments so
that's a house divided against itself on
a lighter note but why is it important
to be unified Matthew 12:30 he who is
not with me is against me he who does
not gather with me scatters abroad
That's A house divided against itself
why is that why does the enemy want us
to be divided he knows that on the day
of Pentecost the strength of the New
Testament Church was their Unity amen
Acts 2 and verse one when the day of
pent Pentecost had fully come they were
all with one Accord in one place and
what else happened verse 46 of Acts
chapter 2 so continuing daily with one
Accord in the temple and breaking bread
from house to house notice they ate
their food with gladness and simplicity
of heart they had this beautiful Unity
they had all things in common they were
not fighting about doctrines but the
devil says I'm going to create all these
churches let them all argue with one
another and all claim to be following in
the same book so what do we do as a
people we say in our Bible Q&A in our
sermons let God's word decide what we're
going to say so that the words of the
Apostle Paul can be fulfilled in 1
Corinthians
12:25 that there should be no Schism in
the body that the members should have
the same care for one another don't
divide by the house mhm good Council
thank you Pastor now we have uh another
question and the last question Jan will
be answering this one came from Jerry
thank you Jerry's from South Carolina he
sent a text and it says when is it
necessary to be re-baptized okay thank
you very much uh we have
one one uh potential answer in Acts 19
verse 1 and onward let's go ahead and
read it and it happened while Apollos
was at Corinth that Paul having passed
through the upper regions came to
Ephesus and finding some disciples he
said to them did you receive the Holy
Spirit when you believed so they said to
him we have not so much as heard whether
there is a Holy Spirit and he said to
them into what then were you baptized so
they said into John's baptism then Paul
said John indeed baptized with a baptism
repentance saying to the people that
they should believe on him who would
come after him that is on Christ Jesus
when they heard this they were baptized
in the name of the Lord Jesus So reading
this helps us to understand that when
you learn new truths they learned the
new truth about Jesus Christ and about
the Holy
Spirit they were re-baptized they had
already been been baptized with John the
Baptist but new truth they were re
baptized uh now there is uh another way
we see that that the church sees U
evidence of this or that you can be
re-baptized and that is when people that
are walking with the Lord turn their
backs on the Lord separate themselves
from the Lord are gone 1 2 3 15 18 20
years they're living as uh Sinners
they're living in the world then through
the blessing of the Holy Spirit
appealing to their heart
they understand that they should repent
and they come back into the church into
the fold so they were living like the
devil but now they want to live
following the Lord in this instance
people have asked for rebaptism in the
church recognizes oh you want to renew
your Covenant with the Lord you renew
your relationship with the Lord and the
church sees that it is reasonable to
re-baptize these people so you have new
truths and people separating from the
Lord as reasons why you may want to be
re-baptized and the the church accepts
these things based on the scriptures and
based on the reasonable consideration of
a person turning turning away but then
coming back to the Lord amen thank you
so much well Mike from South Africa sent
in a question and Pastor LOM would you
please answer why does Jesus love us
even though we don't always do the right
things well I'm going to start by saying
praise God
amen you know the one reason why that is
because God is love amen he loves us
with an Everlasting Love Therefore with
loving kindness he draws us the Apostle
Paul says it is the goodness of God that
leads us to repentance so let's let's
not let's not presume on the mercy of
God let's not say well because he loves
me I'm going to continue living the way
I want Paul says no no don't allow God's
grace to be a license to sin do we
continue in sin that Grace May abound
and Paul says certainly not no this
grace is a perfect opportunity for you
to turn your life over to the Lord he
loves us because his love is a Divine
love it's not a conditional love he
doesn't love us because you know what
finally my kids are getting it right now
I love them that's what parents do when
your kid mess up they say would you go
and straighten out your son when he gets
a A on the test and he graduates with a
4.0
look at my son you know we identify with
the success and we do not identify with
the failure I heard a saying many years
ago failure is always an orphan success
has many mothers we always want to
identify with the success but not with
the failure here's the beauty of it but
while we were yet
sinners God demonstrated his love
towards us in that while we were yet
sinners Christ died for us read the
second half of Romans 5 it'll throw your
heart he didn't wait he didn't wait and
Peter says maybe scarcely for a
righteous man maybe somebody might dare
to die but and then Paul chimes in but
maybe for a good man someone maybe
perhaps might die but God demonstrates
his love towards us in that while where
we yet sinners that's just who God Is So
Brethren the Christian journey is not
about God loving us and then not loving
us he always loves us the Christian
journey is about whether you love him
that's the biggest issue if you love him
then there's an obligation and a
blessing waiting for you on the other
side of the decision to be obedient to
the word of the Lord the Christian
journey is not an easy Journey but it's
a blessed Journey yes I'm sure that we
both all of us have grown over the last
five years amen and that's just the
Christian Journey he accepts us as we
are 1 John 3:2 beloved now we are
children of God and it has not yet been
revealed what we shall be but we do know
that when he is revealed we shall be
like him for we shall see him as he is
but look at verse one behold what manner
of love the father has bestowed on us
that we should be called children of God
that's love so if you're not doing right
don't say well you know how much time do
I have left I know somebody that says
when I'm 33 I'll give my life to the
lord well they're now 64 and they still
haven't given their lives to the Lord
you don't know what tomorrow is going to
bring you have no idea how much time
God's grace is going to be reaching out
to you so don't say well will he love me
because I'm doing wrong still and keep
doing wrong no repent and be converted
that your sins may be blotted out that
the blessings of God will come to you
and finally James 4:17 if you know that
you should be doing right don't persist
in doing evil the Bible says to him who
knows to do good and does not do it to
him it is sin A Dangerous Ground to
ignore the voice of God and he is
faithful and just to forgive us of our
sins first john9 yes and cleanse us from
all unrighteousness thank you for that
amen amen what a joy
really truly to be around this table
with listening to these answers and
thank you so much for being part of the
program the program is your program
because your questions your Curiosities
are important and with that last
question um the L lord loves us in spite
of us right and when we there's never a
time that we cannot approach God so
don't feel that you're filthy dirty and
sinful God is always waiting for you
without Open Arms he's willing and able
to listen to your heart to your voice
and he will transform your life just
turn it over to him well we're going to
go to a pause right now and we will be
right back after this
information if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at
bqa 3abn.org
from God's word well welcome back well
we're going to just um have a few
thoughts to end the program go ahead
Pastor L well you know the the topic I'd
like to just kind of put a cap on
because we're living in a very different
Society than uh every every amount every
few days and few years something is
changing in society but remember the
Lord does not change I would encourage
you to really read God's word on the
topic of adornment on the topic of how
we worship on making decisions about
what's right and what's wrong let us not
allow our opinions to be the
predominating factor here's the beauty
the Lord wants to clothe us with his
righteousness the world wants to clothe
us with that which is just a substitute
for the glory of God choose God's way is
best amen thank you and Johnny well I
would like to talk about uh you know the
person that sent the question about
rebaptism there may be someone listening
that is wondering can I come back to the
Lord after what I've done and after I
have been gone for so long yes in the
prodal the story of The Prodigal Son
shows us that God is already appealing
to your heart and will meet you a great
way off don't hesitate come to the Lord
and as it says in 1 John chapter 1:9 he
will receive you and he will cleanse you
and forgive you and clothe you with his
righteousness amen amen well thank you
Pastor L Kang it's been a pleasure and
Johnny it's been a pleasure sure do
thank you family at home for being part
of the program and we will be expecting
your comments and questions for future
editions thank you so much for have
joining us in this program see you next
time
[Music]
l